you grew up in brooklyn we're brooklyn
kids yeah he grew up in like the
you know upper astrology park slope
brooklyn justified woke dope yeah and i
grew up where i was like you know it's
blue color
how brooklyn are they hurry brooklyn bro
my mother's born and raised in
bensonhurst oh yeah yeah
yeah out of the family nice you ever go
back there visit her
when i was a kid i used to go back to
see my great-grandmother who was who
died at 98 or something wow
i got good genetics yeah you do you look
good you look you are healthy
both you guys yeah there's a lot of
health out here yeah it's a lot of
you guys breathing so much in new york
no nobody's really bro i got
[ __ ] three i got packets of dayquil
in my pocket right now we're not healthy
kids yeah we get nervous well
the only one i know who doesn't touch
like uh bad food and who's
from andrew schultz doesn't eat bread
yeah well andrew schultz is running new
york city like it's north korea yes okay
he tells us he tells people he doesn't
poop and then that's just what you have
to deal with yeah yeah you know
schulte is our boy but marketing right
he's our [ __ ] it's marketing
and he's our [ __ ] he's really [ __ ]
yeah yeah no we're on the schultz
where we are schultz disciples you know
but it's the thing is if schultz ever
gets a little lippy i'll still [ __ ]
screw his head off yeah yeah that's what
he knows about us yeah yeah
yeah he's like he post boxing videos and
i said all i got to do is tickle your
balls for three seconds yeah and that's
it we'll be in a relationship for two
years you'll never know it [ __ ] hit
you that's right
that's what it is wait a minute that's
how he fights that's how he does
see him coming
at christmas guys don't [ __ ] with me you
being metaphorical right now you know
brian if that kid [ __ ] if if people
like that want to pop off at me yeah
yeah i'll [ __ ] corner them at the
comments
some new or out here at the comment
store and tickle their balls yeah and
the next thing you know
they're bringing me home for holidays
and we're in a gay relationship he's
going all over the world on his sky
miles because he's selling more tickets
to me right now and then he won't even
[ __ ] realize what happened
until it's three years ago that's a
[ __ ] intricate adopted asian baby
before we got here he said if either one
of these guys starts talking [ __ ] he's
going to pop in their lap so quick
they're not going to know what hit them
absolutely
keep talking like it's christmas time
that's how we roll out there that's
right all my friends like to do the same
[ __ ] as i do yeah i think that might be
broken before i'm going to kick your ass
but i
i i it's confused my boxing keep talking
i'm popping that lap
he'll end up in that lap i swear to
[ __ ] god you [ __ ] buy a house
together
absolutely guys we'll do all that [ __ ]
we'll have wedding photos
absolutely i'll get a full sex change
keep talking [ __ ] bro
i don't give a [ __ ] dude yeah
i'll tell brian yeah we'll start bug
chasing whatever you need to do oh
god you know right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah
watch your tongue oh okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[ __ ] disrespect